welcome back to CBS mornings where we're
talking about 10 years since the mass
shooting at Sandy Hook Elementary School
in Newtown Connecticut and the fact that
the families of the victims are still
fighting for change 20 children six
Educators murdered by a young man using
an AR-15 style rifle and since then
there have been nearly 4 300 additional
mass shootings in these United States
where four or more people were killed
recent data show that Firearms used in
assaults and suicides and accidents all
combined are now the leading cause of
death among our nation's children in the
aftermath of Sandy Hook several of the
victims families vowed to fight for
improved safety and gun legislation
Mickey petite sat down with two parents
each of whom lost a son
Dylan um was this gorgeous little boy
with these gigantic blue eyes he was
always smiling and laughing and he had
this really high-pitched sing-songy
voice he was just an absolute Joy I
still can't wrap my head around that
it's 10 years on the last day of
Daniel's life
he uh out of the blue before we went to
school that morning he asked me to show
him something on the piano so I taught
him how to play Jingle Bells that was in
uh the last few hours of his life the
morning of December 14 2012 would be the
last time Nicole Hockley and Mark Barton
ever saw their youngest children
six-year-old Dylan Hockley and
seven-year-old Daniel Barton at what
point did you start to think about
fighting for change gun legislation
safety in schools I started talking
about change at Dylan's memorial service
I didn't know what the change would be
but that something would come from this
this wouldn't just be a senseless
tragedy one month later they helped
launch Sandy Hook promise a non-profit
focused on protecting America's children
from gun violence look for warning signs
and threats it's know the science
programs teach children and adults how
to identify at-risk behaviors and
intervene to get help and there are
signs it's working the programs are used
in more than 23 thousand schools
Nationwide which the group says have
helped stop at least 11 incredible
planned school shooting attacks in seven
states this spectrum of violence is it's
it's an escalating things someone
doesn't go straight to Suicide or
homicide so we're we're focused on what
we call Upstream violence prevention how
do we at the earlier end of that scale
intervene and get help they found an
ally in Connecticut Senator Chris Murphy
newly sworn in just weeks after the
shooting for me the last 10 years has
been about
trying to Rattle this country into
understanding the epidemic of gun
violence is every day there are over a
hundred people dying every single day
from suicides from homicides from
accidental shootings in this country a
new study shows the U.S has reached its
highest number of gun deaths in nearly
30 years accelerating recently with a 20
jump from 2019 to 2021 and in the past
decades since Sandy Hook there have been
nearly 4 300 mass shootings 38 of them
at schools one took the lives of 17
students and staff at Marjory Stoneman
Douglas High School in Parkland Florida
in 2018. we are going to be the kids
that you read about in textbooks we are
going to be the last mass shooting to me
the emergence of students after Parkland
as the leaders of this movement in many
ways is you know a story of why we have
now begun to see success legislatively
six success he says in the form of the
new bipartisan safer communities act but
I'm here on this floor
to beg to literally get down on my hands
and knees and beg my colleagues
find a path forward here the bill became
federal law this summer just 31 days
after 19 students and two teachers were
murdered at Robb Elementary School in
Uvalde Texas it's the most significant
gun-related legislation in 30 years and
includes enhanced background checks for
people ages 18 to 21 invest money into
Mental Health Resources and provides
funding to States for red flag laws
which enable authorities to confiscate
guns from individuals deemed dangerous
is it enough it doesn't solve the
epidemic but it saves thousands of lives
there are some people who said well this
isn't Universal background checks this
isn't a ban on assault weapons it's not
worth it well like we're saving lives
there has been change at the state level
two since Sandy Hook the number of
states requiring background checks on
all handgun sales went from 14 to 21 19
States added red flag laws and eight
have banned assault rifles including
Connecticut assault rifles account for
more than 85 percent of mass shooting
deaths has
your work in this journey you took on
together helped in the healing process
helped you through grief
that's that's a tough one
um
yeah yes I mean short answer yes it's a
paradox because it's helping because
it's doing something
and it's helping because it's providing
a legacy and impact and change but it's
also constantly re-traumatizing so it's
it can be helpful for healing and
damaging at the same time how do you
want your sons to be remembered
first of all I want people to know who
Daniel was to look at his little face
and think about that beautiful robust
life full of happiness and understand
that that was taken away violently and
then to think what can I do to be part
of the change to make sure that that
doesn't happen again and I want them to
look at my son and see their own
children in his eyes and think about
what can you do
as a parent grandparent Aunt uncle
to take meaningful action so that this
never happens to you
or anyone or anyone
Barton and Hockley want us to remember
all the lives lost 10 years ago today 20
students and six Educators to learn more
about each of them you can visit my
Sandy
hookfamily.org I've spoken with Nicole
and Mark several times in the last
decade and I'm always struck by their
strength and the work that they've done
they've done is remarkable I I want to
point out again their crisis center
Sandy Hook promise has helped stopped at
least 11 school shootings that's
remarkable that's not something we we
hear or able to talk about in the news
because a lot of times these schools
want to remain anonymous right and the
way that it happened is they received
the tips from students and then they
contacted the schools you know when you
also think about they have mourned the
loss of their children longer than their
children were alive that's always
something that strikes me and I've heard
parents say please don't call it a
10-year anniversary which you know I
hadn't thought about it that way they
said because an anniversary is normally
celebratory positive it's a positive
thing and they're asking all of us think
it's a good message to send to the
public say it was 10 years ago to
but please don't use the word it's a
dividing line it splits their life into
before and after and then using the
after to try to make sure other families
are not in this situation effort Nicola
Mark asked us to call it a remembrance
today remembrance that's what we'll do
Nikki thank you very much